[Music]
hey you guys time once again for tombs
of terror my little book review series
that i've been doing on here for quite a
while uh at this point
so uh here's an author that again
i guess because i haven't really been
keeping up so much uh prior to the last
couple years when i started reading a
lot of new horror again but i hadn't
really keep been keeping up with a lot
of new horror writers so here's another
writer that has written a [ __ ] [ __ ]
ton of novels and who is also actually
uh has been the president of the dallas
fort worth writers workshop uh because
he's from texas for a couple of years at
this point and yet
i had never heard of him or read any of
his stuff
and his name is russell c o'connor
so i decided while i was going through
my recommendations on my kindle
unlimited subscription uh and this came
up and it was free to read so i decided
i would rectify this oversight and uh
the novel that sounded most interesting
to me was one called the jackal man now
this boo this book originally came out
in 2009 i believe the first edition but
the edition i read which i guess is the
second or third edition uh was actually
published in 2016.
i don't know what the difference is
between the editions i think the
cupboards are different but you know i
don't know about the uh the interior
so because it's called the jackal man
you can probably surmise that this is a
basically a monster story
and i gotta say uh if you're a fan of
real fast-paced kind of action horror uh
that has like a pretty gory and a pretty
high like body count and has a sort of
like urban legend or small town legend
like rural legend type of vibe to it
then this should be like right up your
alley i would imagine like if you like
stuff about i don't know like monsters
that are based on like bigfoot or
sasquatch or something like that where
it's just like an urban legend type of
monster but turns out to be real so yeah
if you like that kind of stories then
you probably really really dig this one
so what we have the novel actually
starts with a prologue
which is sort of told as though it's an
urban legend
so in this prologue it's only a couple
pages long there's two kind of teenage
boys and they've been out for a drive
and they're out past their curfew
so they decide to take a shortcut back
home which is never a good thing to do
in horror stories but you know i digress
so this shortcut involves them having to
take
this sort of isolated two-lane road
that's right on the edge of town
and it doesn't really have a name but
all the locals just call it the dark
road because it's basically dark it has
like a bunch of trees like hanging over
it and then it kind of opens up into a
field so it's like woods and then it's
like a field and there's not really
anybody that lives on it or anything
like that
now nobody really takes this road after
dark because everybody in town pretty
much
is afraid of this local legend uh which
is a monster known as the jackal man
now despite this thing being called the
jackal man it's actually not really like
a jackal as in it's not dog-like it's
not a werewolf in other words
it's actually kind of more i mean
according to the people in town that
claim to have seen it because again it's
sort of like a mothman type thing where
although i kind of feel like more people
in this town believe in it and have seen
it
than otherwise but it's kind of like a
similar kind of thing where it's like a
small town and you have like this
monster and like a few people have seen
it and blah blah
so this monster despite being called the
jackal man is actually kind of described
as more cat-like people say it looks
kind of more like a big like a cheetah
or a jaguar or something like that but
tall and like usually walking on two
legs although it can run on all fours as
well so it has like a big long stripy
tail and that kind of [ __ ] and it has um
like these really really bright like
glowing green eyes like radioactive like
green eyes
now these two kids that are in this car
like one of them doesn't believe in the
jackal man but the other one is like are
you [ __ ] serious that we're driving
down the dark road because what if the
jackal man gets is he's like oh that's
just like a story or whatever but
obviously because this is told like an
urban legend uh the two kids get
killed by the monster like the monster
basically jumps up like their car like
turns their car over and uh or makes
their car crash and then like rips their
throats out and that's kind of the end
of it
so after this opening which is very
intriguing then we cut ahead to like our
main part of the story and this happens
some indeterminate time later i don't
know how many years it is later but i
guess it's like some several years later
so the main part of the story involves
our protagonists who are the stanford
family
now the dad frank who's pretty much the
main character like other like the son
willie kind of like factors into it too
but frank is kind of like the main
character
now he's kind of the sort of like
abrasive dude a little bit unhappy with
his lot in life
now he's been working as a foreman
on this uh mall construction project and
presumably dallas fort worth i think
that's where the first part of the story
is told
and this mall construction project is
like way behind schedule
and he's afraid that like his ass is
grass right because he's really behind
on this and he feels like he's gonna get
in trouble
so he ends up getting a visit from the
owner of the company which is this dude
named lyles who is kind of like he's
like the son of the guy that originally
uh you know built the company and that
guy just died so this guy has your
standard kind of like entitled rich boy
kind of [ __ ] attitude you know what i
mean where he's just kind of like you
have to do whatever i said you know he's
like that kind of like douchey character
so lyles comes to see frank and frank is
like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna get fired because
i'm so behind on this mall thing
but he's surprised that lyles actually
offers him
kind of what sounds like sort of a good
deal
he's like okay the company is building
this housing complex like in this little
town called asheville which i think they
specify is about three i don't know if
it's a real place asheville texas um but
it's about three hours outside of dallas
fort worth he's like yeah we're building
a housing complex out there
and the foreman on the job just got
fired
and i think it's 19 houses and he's like
a couple of them are done but the other
ones are in various stages of being done
and he's like we really want this
housing complex done by like the end of
the summer like by the end of august and
we think you're the guy to do it he's
like so if you go out there and you take
this job you'll get like a big huge
bonus and we even rented you like a nice
house like for you and your family to
stay in and you know it'll be really
cool
so frank is kind of like well it sounds
a little bit too good to be true
but frank just pretty much jumps on it
almost immediately like without even
asking his wife or anything because he's
like look um you know my wife is out of
work she's looking for a job but she
hasn't been able to find anything and we
need the money
and also he kind of figures maybe this
will almost be even though he has to
work and stuff like that he's like maybe
the change of scenery will
kind of get our family back on track
because their family's been having like
a lot of tensions and problems um him
and trisha have been kind of at each
other's throats they seem like they're
kind of sick of each other uh she's been
out of work so she's under a lot of
stress and there's just all this kind of
[ __ ] going on and then their main thing
too is that they have this 13 year old
son named willy
who
uh you know he kind of hit puberty and
then he started you know like dressing
like a mall goth and he started kind of
you know
like he pierced his tongue and spiked
his hair and has big jenkos and [ __ ]
like that and he's kind of like causing
a lot of problems in school and he ended
up getting expelled
so
at this point trish is like i don't know
what we're gonna do with them it's like
we can't afford a private school it's
like i can't really homeschool him it's
like what the [ __ ] are we gonna do with
this kid because he's being a brat they
also have a younger daughter named casey
who i think is maybe five six seven
something like that although she doesn't
really factor into the story too much
it's mostly the main characters are kind
of like frank and willie and trisha kind
of comes into it but it's not really
from her perspective when you're seeing
things from certain perspectives it's
usually from frank's perspective
willie's perspective or the perspective
of like one of the guys in asheville
who's like a cop so there's that
so they figure okay well uh trisha's mad
because uh you know frank didn't tell
her just like took this job hey we're
moving three hours away like without
consulting her first but he's able to
like talk her into it it's like it'll
just be like it's just temporary it'll
just be like a vacation you know it'll
be fine you'll see and i'm gonna get
like a lot of money uh so she's like
okay fine so they make the drive uh to
asheville and this is a really really
small kind of pretty like rednecky kind
of like backward place about three hours
as i said outside of dallas fort worth
area now they pull up to the house that
the company rented for them and they're
like wow this is actually like much
nicer than we you know it's nicer than
our house at home and it's like you know
it's two stories and it's really big and
stuff like that so they're like wow
maybe this will be like pretty cool
after all
now when they go in the house uh you
know they do think it's a little bit
weird that the former foreman who lyle
said got fired he had been living in
this house as well obviously while he
was working at the site
and they're like that's really weird his
name was wesley
left wesley gammon i think was his name
and he's like and he left all his
clothes here like they go in the closet
in the bedroom and like all the dudes
clothes are still there and also he left
a bunch of food like so there's a bunch
of food in the fridge which has gone bad
because he hasn't been there for such a
long time they're like that's a little
strange wonder where he went like
without his clothes but they're like oh
well what are you gonna do and then
there's also kind of a thing where where
frank like goes out on the porch and he
sees there's like a headless squirrel
out there and he's just kind of like
okay gross like about nature or whatever
so but foreshadowing you know
now not long after this though even
though as i said they they seem like
everything is like oh cool and
everything like that but frank soon uh
begins to grasp
the scale of the [ __ ] that has
fallen into his lap this thing that he
has undertaken
he goes out to the site to check it out
and discovers a few things that lyles
failed to tell him
he finds out for example that the ground
that the housing development is being
built on
is this really really hard clay
which means that they can't just dig
into it like normal they actually have
to have this guy who's actually like
kind of a funny character this old guy
named cracker who's like missing a bunch
of fingers and stuff he's like a
dynamite expert
and he's blown himself up a bunch of
times the dialogue in this is actually
pretty funny that was like one of the
best things about it was like this
funny-ass dialogue uh but yeah so they
have to have they have to buy all this
expensive dynamite and have to have this
guy out there like blowing stuff up like
doing controlled explosions to in order
to like dig the foundations for these
houses because the ground is so hard so
he's like once he finds that out he's
like okay i promised that we would have
this done by the end of august and he's
like and now i don't think there's any
way that that's gonna happen because
that's like so much extra work
not only that uh he's finding it really
hard to
find a crew at least of locals that are
going to work on the site because the
field where these houses are being built
is right along the dark road which you
know according to the locals that's the
jackal man's territory and everybody is
afraid of the jackal man so
he's like you know we don't want to like
rile the dude up so you know the the
monster so why you know we don't want
you here we don't want anything built
out there
now he does actually manage through one
of his supervisors to get like some like
mexican migrant workers
but you know only a day or two after
frank gets there there's like a really
horrible incident
involving a guard dog so again trigger
warning for cruelty to animals because
some bad [ __ ] happens to like some
animals in this but a really [ __ ] up
thing happens on the site like having to
do with a guard dog that they hired and
that spooks a lot of people too so some
of the people like walk off the job so
there's that as well so it's just kind
of like all this [ __ ] deal that he
has to deal with
also it seems like everybody in town
is really
hostile and like not even low-key
hostile like overtly hostile they're
really not making a secret of the fact
that look we don't want you people here
we don't want houses to be built out
there why the [ __ ] did they even buy the
land you can't even build on it no one's
gonna buy those it's like you know
because no one wants to live right in
jackal man territory so it's like we
don't want you here you're [ __ ]
everything up so
everybody is like hostile toward him
toward his kid and just everything so
it's like really really bad also uh as
if this wasn't enough [ __ ] that
frank has to deal with he also finds out
that lyles who was the one who hired him
to go out here and like build these
houses
doesn't actually give a [ __ ] if the
houses are done or not i mean it's
basically kind of like well this is my
dad's company he bought this land or
whatever but it's like they're kind of
like we just wanted somebody out there
like to blame like when the whole
project goes tits up and so frank kind
of got finagled into it so he's like so
he doesn't really care as much as lyles
is talking about yeah we have to have
these done by blah blah blah he doesn't
really give a [ __ ] if it's done or not
and if it's if it's a disaster then all
the better you know what i mean
now there are a couple towns people that
are sort of friendly or a little more
welcoming one of these is a local
detective named shruff so frank kind of
befriends shruff but
shruff is kind of
i mean all the locals like him it's like
a very small town everybody knows each
other but everybody's kind of like oh
it's this guy again because shruff
not only does he believe that the jackal
man is real which most of the townsfolk
do
but he is like obsessed with
proving it and you find out later like
why he's so adamant that it really
exists but so so there's that
and he's sort of at odds with frank who
has just come to the town and i have to
say that frank he's not a real likeable
character he's kind of an [ __ ] he's
kind of a dick he comes into this town
and like yeah most of the people in this
town are jerks but he's kind of a jerk
too and he just like comes in and he's
like well i can't believe like you
people believe
in this stupid urban legend and this is
like making my job like way harder than
it needs to be just because all you
people believe in this stupid crap and
obviously this doesn't exist but
you know him and shruff still kind of
strike up a little bit of a friendship
um or at least yeah i guess yeah i guess
it's kind of like a friendship even
though obviously shruff like really
absolutely doesn't believe in the jack
does believe in the jackal man and is
trying to tell frank you know yes this
thing is real and it's out there and
this is a real problem that has to be uh
dealt with
there's also kind of like a wild card
aspect and it's like this really weird
hunter type character like who kind of
looks like steve irwin or crocodile
dundee or something and his name is
deegan and he just kind of like
mysteriously shows up in town and he's
like hey i've he's kind of like you know
the guy from the most dangerous game
where he's like oh you know i've hunted
like all animals like all over the earth
and it's like i know that the jackal man
is in this town and it's real and i want
to hunt it because that'll be like a
really good feather in my cap or
whatever and he's like look i'll even
hunt him just i'll keep out of your hair
and i'll just hunt him like you don't
have to pay me i just want to do it like
for the glory of it so there's that but
he's kind of sinister too and you don't
really know exactly what his agenda is
so he's kind of like creeping around in
the background as well
so after all of that set up uh it starts
to get like this sort of escalating
series of you know really violent bloody
incidents people disappear people get
chased by what maybe a monster
willy the kid he kind of uh befriends
these two other punk kids and he starts
getting into trouble and so all this
other kind of stuff happens so all the
scary [ __ ] like all the people
disappearing or turning up eviscerated
or whatever all seems to be centering
around this construction site
and uh even though at first frank is
like some human person must be doing
this or like pulling the strings or
trying to like [ __ ] me over and maybe
lyles is behind it maybe deegan is
behind it maybe he's doing all these
things to like make me look bad or to
like make the company look bad or to
scare people uh to scare the company off
the land because the locals don't want
them there but as the time goes on um he
kind of has to like maybe reassess his
beliefs a little bit uh because as his
friends and family kind of end up
endangered
uh he kind of
and ends up kind of like face to face
with something like really uh really not
what he um
not what not what he believed in not
what he expected
so as i said if you're really into this
is very much an action horror book it's
very very fast-paced it's very
action-oriented
so if you like anything like that that's
based around kind of like an urban
legend type monster i mean this is a
monster that
you know as far as i know it's not like
a real urban legend in the sense that
you know that there's a place called
asheville that actually has this monster
legend so it's not like mothman or
bigfoot or the jersey devil or anything
like that but it's similar like it's a
long similar line so if you like
something like that but it's like it has
an urban legend flavor to it but like
the monster it turns out to be real then
you will probably be really really into
this i actually ended up reading it
almost the whole thing in a single
sitting i think i read like the first
maybe like 10 of it like one night and
then like the next day i just read the
whole thing like straight through and
it's not short i mean it's not super
long but it's 400 something pages so
you know i read it pretty quick because
it was it just moves along like at a
really good clip now as i said if you
absolutely must have a likable
protagonist
you might be in trouble because frank is
kind of a douche like you can kind of
see where he's coming from
but he does come off a little bit like a
jerk and a little bit arrogant uh so
there is kind of that type of [ __ ] as
well
so it didn't bother me but i can see how
it might bother some people if the whole
thing isn't from his perspective a lot
of it is some of it's from willie's
perspective like the 13 year old kid and
some of it is from shruff's perspective
like the detective so it's not just him
like through the whole thing but he does
come across as like a bit of an ass so
you know know that going in so you know
if you have to have like a a likable
main character then you know you might
have an issue with that
uh only other criticism i think i wish a
little bit more had been done with
deegan the hunter because i mean on the
one hand i do like that they left the
character kind of mysterious
but
i would have liked slightly more like of
his backstory like what
i don't know i did like i guess i wanted
his like motivation like maybe expanded
upon a little bit more because i was
kind of like
wow this guy is like what the [ __ ] is up
with this dude you know what i mean
because he was like a really interesting
character and he's in it quite a bit but
i wasn't entirely sure like why he was
doing what he was doing i mean it sort
of explained but not maybe not as much
as i wanted it to be
so there's that uh there were kind of
some uh
quite a few like spelling and
grammatical errors in this which you'd
think would have been correct because
like i said this isn't the first edition
the first edition came out in 2009 but
you know it's i'm not gonna like ding
the book too hard for that because i see
that in a lot of books these days even
ones that are published by big
publishers i guess it's because maybe
they don't
maybe companies don't want to pay like
to hire editors anymore or the editors
they can like are you know they don't
pay them enough like for the editors to
care i don't really know
but there were kind of like a lot of
spelling grammatical errors in this
enough that i kind of like noticed it
but as i said that happens in a lot of
books so i'm not gonna get like too
[ __ ] annoyed about it so there's that
but overall uh this is just a really fun
action-oriented monster story uh with an
urban legend kind of flavor to it which
i really like so if that sounds like
something you'd be into if you have
kindle unlimited you can read it for
free and obviously you can buy the
paperback as well if you want to and
that will do it for this tomes of terror
i will see you guys on the next one bye